with rectangular coordinates that's like
a left and right up and down that's kind
of like an etch-a-sketch sort of way of
you know locating a point in a plane but
with polar coordinates you're working
more with this circular way of locating
points you've got a radius and then
you've got an angle and that's the way
that you locate your point but the
easiest way to do this is to go ahead
and draw a triangle like I've drawn here
so to get to this point I've gone right
X up Y and those are the coordinates X
comma Y but the other way to get there
is just to draw a radius okay to that
point and you've got this angle here the
central angle and that's another way of
locating the point R comma theta right
but let's go ahead and show you where
these formulas come from and then we'll
do some example problems so the first
one is like this you can see from the
Pythagorean theorem that x squared plus
y squared is equal to R squared right so
that's a key formula and then if you
take the square root of both sides you
can see that R is equal to the square
root of x squared plus y squared okay so
if you're given an x and y value you can
solve for that radius right okay now
let's go ahead and take a look at this
angle here so you can see that if you
take the tangent of theta that's equal
to opposite over adjacent that's Y over
X and if you take the tangent inverse of
both sides you can see that theta is
equal to the tangent inverse of Y over X
right so again if you know the X and the
y values you can do the tangent inverse
to find that angle but now let's go
ahead and take a look at it this is step
further if we take the cosine of theta
right cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
so that's x over R and by multiplying
both sides by R you can see that X is
equal to R cosine theta so you can see
here if we're given a radius and an
angle we can find the x-coordinate and
then the same thing with the sine if we
say the sine of theta that's going to
equal what opposite over hypotenuse
which is y over R by multiplying both
sides by R you can see that Y is equal
to our sine theta so that's these are
the two that we're using in this lesson
switching from the radius and the angle
to the X and the y so let's go to this
first example 6 comma 30 now I always
like to draw a quick diagram just to
kind of see you know what I'm working
with
so basically what this means is you're
going on a radius of six and then you're
rotating 30 degrees okay so it's like
that so there's 30 and there's a radius
of six okay but what we can do now is we
can take the radius which is six times
the cosine of 30 that's going to be our
x-coordinate and we can take six times
the sine of 30 and that's going to be
our our y-coordinate
but remember from your unit circle
what's the cosine of 30 degrees
well it's square root 3 over 2 times the
six all right so the six and the two
reduced that's going to be 3 square root
of 3 and what's the sine of 30 that's
1/2 so 6 times 1/2 is 3 so the location
of this point using rectangular
coordinates or XY coordinates you're
going to go right 3 root 3 up 3 and
that's going to be the location of your
point so let's go to the next example
negative 10 comma PI over 4 so now we've
got the angle in radians again I like to
draw a picture negative 10 we're going
to left 10 and they were rotating
counterclockwise PI over 4 so that's
gonna be rate right here in the third
quadrant so this is a radius of 10 and
we rotated 45 degrees like so so again
same formula we're going to take
negative 10 times the cosine of PI over
4 and negative 10 times the sine of PI
over 4 remember cosine of PI over 4 is
root 2 over 2 times the negative 10 and
then sine of PI over 4 is also root 2
over 2
you can cross reduce here and this is
going to give you negative 5 root 2 and
also negative 5 root 2 so this is going
to be the location of your point using
X&Y rectangular coordinates you're going
to left 5 root 2 down 5 root 2 so I hope
this helped you understand how to work
with polar coordinates and specifically
converting from polar to rectangular and
the next lesson in the next video I'm
going to be doing the reverse how to go
from you know rectangular back to polar
so subscribe to the channel check out
more math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon